so it's kind of a cliche that it's hard
to train your legs properly
with just bodyweight exercises with just
calisthenics
there's plenty you can do for your upper
body whether it's push-ups or dips or
pull-ups
and there's loads of ways to make it
more challenging by changing the lever
arm or by
switching onto one side but training
your legs is more difficult because of
course you're carrying your weight on
your legs all day every day so how do
you
effectively increase that challenge
enough to stimulate growth
and ultimately for many athletes the
answer comes down to well basically
squats
and while squats are great you can't
build a whole workout off of just
one exercise more to the point squats
aren't great for everyone because squats
are quite challenging if you have any
issues with your hip mobility or your
ankle mobility
then you're gonna find that squats a
little bit uncomfortable those with
longer legs can find them a bit ungainly
depending on your hip socket you might
find it more or less difficult then
there are issues like
how far down do you go and is butt wink
really an issue
etc etc so if you're relatively new or
if you want to do
high repetitions and you just don't find
them that comfortable then squats
might not be the perfect option for you
fortunately
as ever there's another fantastic
alternative that's right under our noses
and it is of course the lunge and i'm
going to explain to you why
lunging is particularly fantastic as an
addition to squats or as an alternative
and we're going to look at some of the
different variations you can do as well
so
without any further ado let's dive in
or lunge in
[Music]
so most people know how to lunge i think
that's one of the great things about it
and like the squat it's
pretty hard to get it wrong but let's go
over the basics and look at some
pointers just in case so
all you're essentially going to do is
start from a standing position with your
legs together
then you're going to step forwards you
want to land so that your
feet are about shoulder-width apart
there's no need for them to be in line
that just makes
it much more difficult reduces stability
step forwards
you know further if you can and you want
to land on your heel keep your weight on
your heel
and then you're going to push up back
through the heel as you come back up
try not to do this too quickly so it's a
bounce or you won't really be working
the muscles it'll be more of a
kind of tendon thing and it's not the
end of the world if your knee does hit
the floor at the back
but it's also not ideal because then
you're taking some of the
weight off you're making it slightly
easier for yourself and thereby reducing
the
effectiveness of the exercise but it
won't do you any harm some coaches will
tell you not to let the knee pass the
toe on the front leg but as anyone who
watches this channel or similar channels
will know
that's actually relatively outmoded
advice at this point and we know that
the knee passing the toes can actually
be a great way to strengthen it as long
as you don't have existing issues
and you've done that groundwork in fact
this is quite a nice gentle way so if
you want to lean forwards a little bit
that's a variation that we'll get into
in a bit so now to the good stuff
what is it about the lunge that makes it
such a fantastic exercise well there's
actually
a whole bunch of different things so
first of all the lunge is in some ways
a single legged move it's a unilateral
move except for unlike something like a
pistol squat which is
a challenging and more advanced movement
you are using your back leg to stabilize
and balance which means that this is
something
that someone who's slightly more of a
beginner can do and it's something you
can do with added weight and it's
something you can do
you know in higher repetitions but at
the same time you get many of the same
benefits that you would do from a
completely single-legged exercise so
those
benefits of course are first of all
balance and stability
if you want to strengthen your hips and
your ankles and your stabilizing muscles
to make it less likely that you're going
to
twist an ankle or put your knee out when
you're running especially on uneven
terrain or when changing directions
quickly in sports
then the lunge can help you do that and
in fact as you start to fatigue you'll
notice that keeping your leg straight
is one of the slightly more challenging
aspects of the movement
you might even be able to generate more
strength this way thanks to something
called the bilateral deficit
so the bilateral deficit basically means
that if you try and exert strength from
two
limbs at the same time you won't be able
to generate twice the strength
that you would be able to generate from
one limb at a time so in other words
if you did a leg press with both legs
and you could press let's say 150
kilograms
then you would probably be able to press
more than 75 kilograms with a single leg
and there's obviously
many different factors such as stability
but all things being equal
this is the case and basically what this
means is that if you're training
individually on each side then you can
generate more power
than you otherwise would be able to and
at the same time this is great for
symmetry
if you have an imbalance so that one leg
is stronger or one leg is bigger than
the other which is very common
certainly true in my own case and i've
had a scan to demonstrate this
then moving to a unilateral movement or
a quasi-unilateral movement like this
one
is a great solution to that because when
you do the squat if one starts to get
tired
then the other one can start to
compensate and help and this can lead to
compounding issues over time so making
sure that you're training at least
some unilateral movements can prevent
that from happening and if you imagine
running a huge distance having a little
bit less strength in one leg is going to
be a massive
detriment to you over a long duration
because whilst you might generate a tiny
little bit less power on each stride
that's going to add up over time and
equal a big difference to your overall
time
one of the most popular benefits of the
lunch though is that it's fantastic for
activating
the glutes and this is something that a
lot of people have trouble with
largely thanks to our sedentary
lifestyles where we spend so much time
just
sitting on them squashing them so if
you're someone who has trouble
activating glutes
during a squat which goes for a lot of
people then using the lunge in
conjunction with the squat or as an
alternative
is a fantastic way to go another big
benefit of the lunch is there's a kind
of weighted stretch because as you
dive down into that movement as you
lunge down into that movement you're
going to be stretching that back leg
nicely so it's a brilliant way to
stretch the hip flexors
and this is another very common issue
that we have thanks to our modern
lifestyle sitting at computers we have
tight and short hip flexors so
really this is the perfect antidote to
our modern lifestyles and it's a
brilliant way to build
more athletic performance whether that's
jumping running speed or even high kicks
and scissor splits
at the end of the day we mostly perform
from a single leg whether that's in
sports or in life
and so it makes sense to train on a
single leg and actually the lunge in
itself is a movement that we do use from
time to time for instance when
lunging for a ball or trying to catch
something that falls out of a cupboard
so it's a really functional movement
and one that a lot of us could benefit
from practicing
but as with so many exercises the real
benefits of the lunge come into play
once you begin
experimenting with variations and
progressions and when you start
combining them
with different movements so let's start
with an easier variation if you're
someone who struggles to perform a lunge
because
this does require some stability and
some strength then you can instead use
the
knee and get up so we're going to do
instead is get down onto one knee
stand up get down onto the opposite knee
and if you need added support then of
course you can hold
onto a wall or the side or a friend's
hand in order to stabilize yourself
another obvious variation for the lunge
is to add weight and you can do this
either by
loading your back with a weight as you
would do in a squat
or you can do it by loading your front
with a weight like a goblet squat
or you can hold the weights on either
side like you might do with a
trap bar deadlift
and this is one of the big advantages of
the lunge again because you can add that
weight
without the spinal compression so if you
want to avoid that then
the lunge is your boy
it also means that you can get varied
benefits depending on where you're
holding the weight if you hold the
weights on either side then this means
you're gonna have to use
more hip stability and balance once
again and it's great for improving your
gait
etc in fact you could go one step
further and load
just one side like you're doing a
briefcase carry
hold just a weight in one side and then
lunge and now what you're doing
is you're having to resist that lateral
flexion
and thereby you're training your core at
the same time and this is
once again a great way to build more
stability as well as to build strength
for
lots of everyday tasks like carrying
shopping or carrying a young child
at the same time you can also use an
overhead position hold the weight
overhead and of course you can do this
with a squat as well but it's actually
much easier
with a lunge and so it's a great way to
build up to that as well so there's
plenty of options
if you want to add weight to the
movement
one of my very favorite lunches though
because everyone's got to have a
favorite lunch
is the walking lunge so all you're going
to do here is going to lunge but then
instead of stepping back to the starting
position you're instead going to step
through into another step and then just
keep going and the reason this is so
great is that it maintains a constant
tension
especially if you perform it correctly
with a constant motion you're at no
point going to be
resting at the top of the movement this
will help to build up blood and
metabolites in the lower body
and at the same time it'll build that
strength endurance which i've talked
about so often
having a big max lift is really cool
it's a great
bragging right but it's not as useful in
the real world as being able to be
strong
for a continued amount of time we very
rarely need to lift something really
heavy once we more often have to lift
something
quite heavy lots of times i said this
late so the walking lunge is fantastic
for that
especially if you're going through
varied different terrain in which case
you're building
even more stability especially if you're
wearing barefoot shoes or minimal shoes
and if you think it's too easy then try
covering any significant distance
and then come back to me you can combine
a walking lunge with a weighted lunge
whether you want to make it a
farmer's walking lunge or whether you
want to make it an overhead
walking lunge you can do all kinds of
things like that and of course you can
also lunge walk backwards and this is a
fantastic way to lunge walk if you have
limited space meaning you can lunge walk
forwards and then you can lunge walk
backwards and then repeat and this
slightly changes the activation
it also builds even more stability as
this is a more difficult movement
so if the walking lunge is my favorite
lunge which it is
then my second favorite lunge would have
to be the scissor
jump or the jumping lunge basically what
you're going to do here
is you're going to get down into the
lunge the lower lunge position
on the spot jump up in the air and then
switch your legs over before landing and
then you're just going to
jump straight back up again try and jump
as high as you can
make a real conscious effort to have
that neural drive to
want to jump high and explosively and
this is really fantastic is what you're
actually doing here is you're
building explosiveness plyometric power
off of that single leg in the same
position or a similar position
that you might use when decelerating
running or jumping
not exactly the same but there's a lot
of crossover here in fact the awesome
youtuber pygmy who seems to have been
around forever
sharing tricking tutorials calisthenics
tutorials as well as general fitness
advice
says that the scissor jump is one of the
single moves that gave him the most
gains in terms of his jump height and
his running speed and looking at his
performance
that's enough of a testimonial for me
and it's also something i know that
grant uses a lot so and again what you
can do is you can do as many of these as
you can and then you can switch
immediately to regular lunges
if you want to tax all of your different
energy systems
and build a lot of strength and
endurance at the same time my third
favorite lunge because
apparently we're doing this that would
have to be the back lunge with knee
thrust so we're going to do here is step
backwards into the lunge
then step forwards and thrust your knee
up in the air and then you're going to
step back onto that same leg so you're
going to repeat
all your repetitions on one side and
then the other side and this is great
because you're once again generating
more power and force
it's a very functional movement
obviously if you want to develop knee
strength or kicking strength or
training those hip flexors to bring the
legs up nice and quickly from that
stretched elongated position there's
also another fantastic form of
resistance cardio that gets the heart
rate going
and yeah it's just a brilliant all-round
move and you can even add a little jump
in there as well
so you're jumping up in the air if you
want to make it more difficult still
and the bulgarian split squat which is
also sometimes known as the bulgarian
lunge
is yet another really fantastic movement
and what this one does according to the
glute guy who's really the expert on
glute strength is it allows you to
challenge the glutes more at the top of
the movement at the
higher range of motion and this is
important because normally when you're
lunging all the challenges down the
bottom of the movement it has a very
distinct steep strength curve what this
means is that you're not training it at
that
more stretched position and actually
this is where the glutes are capable of
generating the most
force so really you're really missing
out by putting your leg up onto
something higher up behind you
when you perform the bulgarian split
squat you're essentially fixing this
problem you can do it with weight or
without weight
and if we're talking about guys who like
leg training then of course there's
knees over toes guy
who talks about his atg split squat
where you lean nice and forwards it's
great for building
ankle mobility knee strength of course
that's the whole point and also
even more hip flexor mobility and this
is a fantastic movement
i'm not going to cover it here because
it really deserves its own video also
you should check it out from the source
knees over toes guy has loads of useful
free tutorials
but yeah that's another movement that's
really something of a hybrid between the
squat
and a lunge and of course you combine
all sorts of different movements whether
you're lunging and doing an overhead
press or combining these different
movements
there's lateral lunges if you want to
train in the frontal plane although this
is quite a different move once again
it's somewhat similar to a squat
there's endless variations and all of
them have something unique and cool to
offer so if you're currently training
legs with only body weight and you're
looking for something other than the
squat to perform
then consider lunges because they're
really fantastic movement
they have tons of variations and yeah
they have loads of benefits that even
the squat can't offer
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that would help me out
immensely if you want to see more like
this then subscribe and hit the
bell button if you want to be notified
of each new upload let me know in the
comments down below whether you use
lunges
and whether you intend to after this
video also any additional
variations you have i'd really like to
hear them if you like this kind of
training that focuses on
not only strength but also mobility
endurance and
even things like agility balance focus
creativity
and iq then you're really enjoying my
ebook and training program
super functional training there's a
discount on right now as there has been
since the beginning of the pandemic
and there's a link in the description
down below if you'd like to check that
out
if you just want an introduction to
functional training and what it means
for
the average joe as well as athletes then
check out my print book
functional training and beyond which you
can get from amazon and
a host of other good bookstores either
way thank you so much for watching this
one
and i'll see you next time bye for now
cheesy walk away
i've got my camera